how was class sorry that was my fault
are you okay you just had Zach McLaren's
ball in your face what's his GPA
do you have any books on battle toads
you know video games are now the leading
cause of divorce did you actually order
me a book on that really no
sarcasm is frequently an attempt to
deflect one's ignorance
oh wait you forgot your credit card
oh
he is dating a Zoe what others
you see the dead or he's dumped me
honestly I'm not sure which is worse
make sure Zach takes it easy as symptoms
could get worse what do I do you don't
want him getting worse pretend to be the
other Zoe you've been dating two or
three weeks now right
yeah
sunrise this is Zach's cousin miles he's
in grad school at MIT oh my God a match
for Zoe I
art with an Amnesia patient's cousin
we're all gonna go skiing in the
mountains this weekend you want to go
with us strip of land seven letters
oh how did you know that well done you
two should we eat it we shallow
it's confusing I'm enjoying getting to
know you over again
swing of life
even Zach do you really thinks you're a
good match like we are it's complicated
[Music]
truth you have to go after what you want
and be brave
oh my God you're just giving me rom-com
advice now no it's so fun
[Music]
so what did you do did you have fun what
didn't we do excuse me All PG-13 okay
[Applause]
foreign